i have concluded that there were serious
shortcomings
in the security provided by those
organizations which had responsibility
for it
and also failings and mistakes by some
individuals
when the mistakes and shortcomings set
out in the report
are considered it needs to be at the
forefront of that consideration
that responsibility for what happened
and for causing so many
deaths and serious injuries lies with
salman abadi
the suicide bomber and his brother
hashim
who assisted with the preparations
hashimadi is now serving sentences of
life imprisonment
for offenses including the murders of 22
people
the brothers intended to cause as much
harm as they could
no other person or organization acted
with the intention of causing
any injury or with any idea their
actions or lack of action
would or could assist a suicide bomber
carrying out his evil intentions
there will be those who consider that i
have been over critical
in reaching the conclusions that i have
they will suggest that i have used
hindsight in reaching my decisions
and have made scapegoats of some
individuals
others may consider that i have not been
critical enough
in reaching my conclusions i have
considered
all of the evidence there are not many
people
who like me have heard it all
i have tried to avoid any impermissible
use of hindsight
and above all i have tried to be fair
i was urged by everybody to avoid
looking for scapegoats
i have not looked to blame anyone
but where having considered the evidence
i consider that
individuals have fallen below a proper
standard
in carrying out their important roles in
protecting consequence
i have said so it should be remembered
in relation to a number of the
individuals who are subject to criticism
that once the bomb had been detonated
they went as quickly as they could
into the city room where the bomb had
detonated
and did what they could do to assist the
victims
some will say that if you look at any
incident such as this
in the degree of detail that i have you
will inevitably find
things that have gone wrong that may be
so
but when you are considering an event
which has caused as much
harm and suffering as this attack it is
only right
that the circumstances should be
scrutinized with the greatest care
an important part of the report deals
with what are called missed
opportunities
there were a number of opportunities to
identify salmonella baby's activities as
being suspicious
on the night before he detonated his
bomb
what i cannot say with any certainty is
what would have happened if those
opportunities had not been missed
salman abadi might have been deterred
from committing this outrage
but might have done the same thing
elsewhere
he might have detonated his bomb earlier
in a different location
in or close to the city room
the report deals in details with the
shortcomings in security
i will not go into detail now
and i invite those interested to read
that detail in the report
before forming a judgment for now
i will talk only about some of my
overriding impressions
on the 22nd of may 2017 the threat level
set by the joint terrorism analysis
center was severe
that meant that a terrorist attack was
highly likely
whilst a threat was not specific to any
particular premises the arena was always
a possible target for terrorists
there had been previous attacks in paris
and bavaria
which had shown that popular music
events such as these those held at the
arena
could be a target
everybody concerned with security at the
arena
should have been doing their job in the
knowledge that a terrorist attack
might occur on that night
they weren't no one believed it could
happen to them
the threat level had been that severe
for a period in excess of two and a half
years
and it is difficult to maintain a level
of preparedness over a long
period that is not a criticism of the
threat level
while the threat was high the level
needed to be at severe
it was the responsibility of managers to
ensure
that the message that the threat level
was severe was refreshed
in such a way that people did not become
complacent about
it the essential message
is that all employees need to be on the
lookout
for suspicious behavior which when they
see it
they should report to their relevant
supervisor
employees must know how to identify
suspicious behavior
be encouraged to report it and not feel
that they may be criticized
if it turns out to be a false alarm
further there was insufficient sharing
of information between those people
concerned with security at the arena
another recurring theme in this enquiry
is the need to efficiently share
information with partners
and neighbors the effect of this will be
to greatly increase the efficacy
of the response